we predicted
that the southern district of new york
prosecution uh a district attorney
would be a thorn in the side of donald
trump and his family
long after he was out of office that may
still be the case
but it is georgia that is jumping ahead
very quickly
and has launched a criminal
investigation into donald trump's
supposedly perfect phone call to georgia
officials
saying that they need to find 11 780
votes for him
yes donald trump is under criminal
investigation it's happening
even more quickly than some of us
anticipated it might happen the new york
times reporting
that prosecutors in georgia have started
a criminal probe
into donald trump's attempts to overturn
the election results in
georgia including that infamous phone
call he made
to republican secretary of state brad
raffensberger that's the call
where trump insisted i only need 11
780 votes what are we going to do help
me out here
how can we find these votes uh
fanny willis who is the democratic
prosecutor
in fulton county has now sent a letter
to numerous officials
in state government including brad
raffensberger requesting that documents
be preserved
related to an investigation into
attempts to influence the state's 2020
presidential election so this is notable
for a few different reasons
these notifications to preserve
documents are typical
when there is an investigation that is
taking place
because this is a prosecutor in fulton
county
we know that this is a criminal
investigation that's what it is that's
what it means that's what these
prosecutors investigate
now the letter does not mention donald
trump by name
um but it is related to what donald
trump
did trying to change the outcome of
georgia's election
insisting that these uh officials
should simply find these votes make it
happen
and a copy of this letter that was sent
was obtained by the new york times and
it really
doesn't look good for donald trump now
the
speculation is trump's ultimately going
to be charged with felony election fraud
and that one of the really important um
things to understand is that when it
comes to these
statutes even if you fail to convince
someone to do the thing you want them to
do it is still a crime
uh quote under georgia law it is illegal
to falsify any records used in
connection with an election
or to place false entries in such
records and
any person who solicits requests
commands import tunes or otherwise
attempts to cause
the other person to falsify election
fraud in the first degree
to falsify voting records is guilty of
criminal solicitation to commit election
fraud in the first degree
this is a felony offense and much like
with bribery if you try to bribe someone
and they don't accept the bribe
you're still guilty uh if you i mean
listen when we talk about attempted
murder just because you failed to kill
someone doesn't mean you've committed no
crime and much the same way
even if you fail to induce fraud by
asking someone in this case brad
raffensberger
to find these 11 780 votes
you are still culpable even if you don't
get them to do the thing you're asking
them to do
imagine if georgia ruins donald trump's
life before new york does
everyone expecting southern district of
new york to be the
never-ending thorn and trump side and
georgia jumping ahead very quickly now
from the standpoint of trump's defense
the president the former president is
known for not paying bills of all kinds
in real estate not paying contractors
that he hires to do windows or whatever
it is he needs at different buildings
as uh president known for not paying
legal fees who's going to defend donald
trump and is it still worth it to them
to do it simply to say you're defending
the president
even if you're not going to get paid is
it worth it for the notoriety is it no
worth it for the publicity and the pr i
don't know the answer
but it seems as though donald trump is
going to need a lot a lot of different
lawyers
over the next several years this is just
the start and
uh you know i think from the standpoint
of setting expectations
we know what the defense will be about
fine 780
11 780 votes and we talked about this on
the bonus show yesterday
it is going to be donald trump wasn't
asking someone to commit fraud
donald trump really believed this is
what they'll say we don't know if it's
the truth donald trump
really believed he won in the state of
georgia
and what he was pointing out was it was
only 11
780 votes of margin and that
what trump was saying was we don't need
to fix
every fraudulent vote we just need to
fix eleven thousand seven hundred and
eighty it will go to donald trump's
mindset at the time it will go to donald
trump's beliefs at the time
i have no uh delusion that this would be
an easy case to prove and i've had a
number of lawyers email me
about this reality similar similar to
with perjury
just because you said something untrue
under oath doesn't mean
it's necessarily perjury you have to
prove intent
and that's why it's very difficult to
prove perjury that's why you don't often
see it
prosecuted when incorrect statements are
made
under oath during trials and the same
complexity will come up here that
doesn't mean trump won't need
lawyers to defend him he will and the
question of who is it going to be i
can't imagine it's going to be bruce
castor
i don't think david shone would be
interested in this one nor nor do i
think it's a specialty
so the next months and years are going
to be very interesting but for today
yes a criminal investigation apparently
launched
by georgia into donald trump's
supposedly perfect phone call that's his
designation nobody else is calling it
that
and we will see where that goes tell me
what you expect
in terms of these investigations
criminal civil and otherwise
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and
other protective gear for covid19 and
they're giving my audience 20 percent
off
snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to health care institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over 150 dollars you
can get there by going to
davidpakman.com mask the link is under
this video
and you can save 20 on everything in
their store when you use the coupon code
david